[Musik]
zur Meldung an der militärischen
Anwesenden das ganze
meldet die Ehrenformation gestellt durch
die Garde die Insignia in der Heeres
unteroffiziersakademie die Fahne der
unteroffiziersgesellschaft
Oberösterreich sowie die Absolventen des
Jahrgangs 2022 zur feierlichen
Ausmusterung des Lehrganges feldpilot
Karl Urban angetreten danke mit dem
Festakt beginnen
[Musik]
meldet sich ab
[Applaus]
das ganze
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Zuseherinnen und Zuseher beim Livestream
erstmalig darf ich als Moderator dieser
Veranstaltung eine große Anzahl
höchstrangiger ehren und Festgäste am
Campus der doberik schulkaserne begrüßen
ich tue das mit einer großen Freude
etwas Lampenfieber aber dem
allerhöchsten Respekt
vor der Begrüßung möchte ich sie aber
darüber in Kenntnis setzen dass der
nationale Sicherheitsrat aufgrund der
aktuellen Geschehnisse einberufen wurde
daher können heute die Frau
Bundesministerin und daher
Generalstabschef nicht bei uns in Enns
zu gegensein
an der Spitze aller hier anwesenden darf
ich mit Hochachtung den militärisch
höchst Anwesenden den stellvertretenden
Chef des Generalstabs Herrn generalm
Magister Rudolf Striedinger zur heutigen
Ausmusterung begrüßen
für die hohe Geistlichkeit ist es mir
eine Ehre Herrn Militärbischof dr Werner
Freistädter Herr Militärs dr Karl
Reinhard Trauner
Herrn Erzpriester dr Alexander lappin
und Herrn militäriman Kenan
zu dürfen
in Vertretung des Landeshauptmanns von
Oberösterreich möchte ich Frau
Landeshauptmann Stellvertreterin
Magistra Christine haberlander sehr
herzlich in ihrer Heimatstadt Jens
begrüßen
ich darf begrüßen den amtsführenden
Vorsitzenden der parlamentarischen
bundesheerkommission und Sprecher für
Landesverteidigung der Österreichischen
Volkspartei Herrn Abgeordneten zum
Nationalrat mag Friedrich offenauer
ich möchte in unserer Mitte begrüßen den
Vorsitzenden der Bundesheer Gewerkschaft
Herrn Abteilungsleiter Magister Walter
Hirsch und im Vertretung des
Vorsitzenden des Zentralausschusses im
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
Herrn vizeeutnant Gerald Sapper
die für die Sicherstellung des
einsatzbetriebes entscheidende Bedeutung
unserer Kameraden des militsstandes und
deren Ausbildung wird durch die
Anwesenheit des Präsidenten des
milizverbandes Österreich Herrn
Brigadier dr Johannes kenzbauer und im
Vertretung des Miliz beauftragten Herrn
Oberst Reinhard Guggenberger
unterstrichen
den Bürgermeister der Stadt Enns und
Partner der heeresundoffiziersakademie
darf ich begrüßen Herrn Christian delea
hotko
sehr geehrte Herren und Festgäste die
Ruhe Anzahl an höchstrangigen
Persönlichkeiten aus Politik
Gesellschaft und Militär macht es mir
unmöglich jeden von ihnen einzeln zu
begrüßen
daher erlaube ich mir die folgenden
Damen und Herren stellvertretend bei uns
am Campus der huak begrüßen zu dürfen
ich bitte Sie alle den Applaus für den
Schluss dafür dann aber umso kräftiger
aufzusparen
mit Hochachtung und Respekt begrüße ich
die überleitungsverantwortlichen
direktionsleiter im Bundesministerium
für Landesverteidigung
für die präsidialdirektion Herrn Hofrat
Dr Schavan
für die Direktion Personal Herr
Ministerrat dr Hauser
für die Direktion recht Herr Ministerrat
dr Satzinger
für die Direktion Kommunikation Herrn
Ministerrat Magister
für die Direktion Revision und
beschwerdewesen ein generalmeier
Magister Hamberger
die überleitungsverantwortlichen
direktionsleiter im Generalstab
für die Direktion Ausbildung Herrn
Generalleutnant Magister chicovic
und den Kommandanten der Theresianischen
Militärakademie Herrn Generalmajor magl
mit dem kommando-
Leutnant stessel
für die Direktion Luftstreitkräfte den
stellvertretenden Leiter Herrn Brigadier
Ingenieur Magister Prieler und den
Kommando und Offizier wir haben viel zu
Leutner
für die Direktion Beschaffung ein
Generalmajor Magister motosek
für die Direktion IKT und Cyber ein
Generalmajor magonik
und den kommando_lo
für die Direktion militärisches
Gesundheitswesen Frau brigadir Dr
Sperandio und die kommando-unteroffizier
herrisch
für alle Abteilungsleiter im
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
die Leiterin der Abteilung allgemeine
Personalangelegenheiten und gleichzeitig
stellvertretende
gleichbehandlungsbeauftragte Frau
Abteilungsleiterin Magister
den Leiter der Abteilung Geräte
Personaladministration Herrn
Abteilungsleiter Magister laschal
für alle Anwesenden Militärkommandanten
die Militärkommandant von
Niederösterreich Herrn Brigadier mag
für alle Brigade und
Bataillonskommandanten und Kommando und
Offiziere im Besonderen
nachbarschaftlicher Verbundenheit den
Kommandanten der vierten
panzergrenadierbrigadeier mag
und die Vertretung des mit der Führung
beauftragten Kommandanten der
Luftunterstützung Herrn Oberst Windhager
mit dem Kommando Herrn Vize Leutnant
ganz besonders darf ich alle
Kommandanten der Verbände und Einheiten
begrüßen die die
heeresunteroffiziersakademie bei der
Ausbildung der vor ihnen angetretenen
Wachtmeister nicht nur bei diesem
ausmusterungsjahrgang unterstützt haben
die Anwesenden Bataillonskommandanten
des staatsbataillon 3 des
Panzerstabsbataillon 4 des
staatsbataillon 6 und des staatsbutton 7
sowie die Kommandanten der lehrkompanien
für alle Kommandanten der
waffengattungschulen den Kommandanten
der heereslogistikschule Herrn Brigadier
Magister Lampl
für alle ehemaligen Kommandanten der
Heeres undoffiziersakademie Herrn
Generalleutnant Professor magisterschule
und Herren Generalmajor Egger dem wir
auf diesem Weg sehr herzlich zur heute
in Wien erhaltenen Beförderung
gratulieren möchten
den Präsidenten der österreichischen
unkoffiziersgesellschaft wir haben
vize-leutnant Auinger und mit ihm alle
Präsidenten und Funktionsträger in der
Bundesorganisation und den Landesstellen
es ist uns ein besonderes Anliegen die
Angehörigen der Wachtmeister des
ausmusterungsjahrgangs 2022 zu begrüßen
wir hätten sie sehr gerne persönlich bei
uns gehabt müssen uns aber aufgrund der
Pandemie auf die Videoübertragung
beschränken wir suchen um Ihr
Verständnis
nicht zuletzt möchte ich aber sie
geschätzte Wachtmeister des
ausmusterungs Jahrgangs 2022
feldpilot Karl Urban an ihrer Heimat der
Heeres unoffiziersakademie ganz
besonders begrüßen
sie sind der Grund warum wir heute
versammelt sind herzlich willkommen
Kameraden
sehr geehrte Herren und Festgäste ich
bitte nun und um ihren abschließenden
aber dafür umso kräftigerer Applaus
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf
das Wort an den Kommandanten der Heeres
und offiziersakademie Herrn Oberst
Magister Klingenschmid übergeben
sehr geehrter Herr general major sehr
geehrte Frau Landeshauptmann
Stellvertreter hohe Geistlichkeit
hochgeschätzte Generalität
wertekommandanten und Kommando und
Offiziere liebe Gäste vor Ort und bei
der Videoübertragung es ist eine
Auszeichnung sie im Rahmen des heutigen
Festakts an der
heeresunteroffiziersakademie begrüßen zu
dürfen dieser Festakt ist ein wichtiges
Ritual in diesem Rahmen die hier
angetreten Absolventinnen und
Absolventen der
unteroffiziersgrundausbildung zum
Wachtmeister befördert und damit
offiziell in das Unteroffiziers Chor des
österreichischen Bundesheeres übernommen
werden
das führt mich gleichzeitig zur
wichtigsten Personengruppe des heutigen
Tages sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister des ausmusterungs Jahrgangs
2022 feldpilot Karl Urban
wir die heeresunteroffiziersakademie die
waffengattungsschulen und die
lehrcompanien haben sie in der
vergangenen Monaten bei
Weiterentwicklung zum Unteroffizier
begleitet und unser Bestes gegeben Ihnen
für diesen großen Schritt die
erforderliche Unterstützung zu bieten
für das aus meiner Sicht insgesamt
erfreulicher Gesamtergebnis waren aber
überwiegend sie selbst verantwortlich es
war und ist ein Privileg mit ihnen zu
arbeiten und ich bin stolz darauf was
Sie was wir gemeinsam erreicht haben ich
bedanke mich nicht nur für ihre Leistung
sondern auch für Vertrauen ihre
Kameradschaft und die offenen Worte in
vielen guten Gesprächen im und abseits
des Dienstes ich möchte einen versichern
dass ihre Meinung ernst genommen wird
mit diesem Festakt übergebe ich sie in
die kundigen Händler der hier
versammelten Kommandanten und Kommando
und Offiziere die ab Montag in der
schwerwiegenden Verantwortung stehen
Ihnen trotz voller Auftragsbücher die
Umsetzung des Erlernten in der Praxis
und das Sammeln der Zwinger der
erforderlichen Erfahrung zu ermöglichen
ich bin sehr zuversichtlich dass sie in
ihren heimatverbänden gut aufgenommen
werden und diese so wichtige
Unterstützung erhalten
ein Blick auf die tragischen Ereignisse
in der nur knapp 1000 km entfernt
lucarine unterstreicht die Wichtigkeit
guter Ausbildung insgesamt sehr deutlich
es sind Kommandanten wie wir sind die
dort mit einer gemessen an den Umständen
wahrscheinlich ungenügenden Ausbildung
im Kriegseinsatz für die
Selbstbehauptung ihrer Heimat einstehen
und für die Auftragserfüllung die Moral
und letztlich das Überleben der ihnen
anvertrauten Soldaten verantwortlich
sind
der militärische Einsatz bleibt damit
auch in der Ausbildung einen Akademien
Schulen und bei der Truppe das Maß aller
Dinge um im militärischen Einsatz
bestehen zu können braucht es aber nicht
nur militärisches können es erfordert
starke Persönlichkeiten Mut Disziplin
und vor allem Vertrauen in unsere
Kampfgemeinschaft die nur einsatznähe
Ausbildung und Übungen in der dafür
erforderlichen Zeit Formen können
ich wünsche Ihnen bei der Verfolgung
dieses Maßstabes viel Erfolg Zuversicht
und die Unterstützung ihrer Angehörigen
bewahren Sie sich den Fokus und das
Engagement dass wir in den vergangenen
Monaten bei ihnen beobachten konnten
erwerben und erhalten Sie sich das
Vertrauen ihrer Soldaten Kameraden und
Vorgesetzten führen Sie mutig und durch
Vorbild geben Sie sich nicht damit
zufrieden wie die Dinge gerade sind
sondern sie arbeiten Sie aktiv daran mit
dass österreichische Bundesheer so zu
gestalten wie es sein sollte und
spätestens im Einsatzfall auch sein muss
es lebe das österreichische Bundesheer
es lebe die Heeres
unterversicherungsakademie es lebe der
ausrüstungsjahrgang 2022 feldpilot Karl
Urban
[Applaus]
geschätzte ehren- und Festgäste ich darf
jetzt zum Militärgeistlichen Teil
überleiten hören Sie zuerst einen Choral
gespielt von der Gardemusik daran
anschließend wird die
militärgeistlichkeit ihre Worte an Sie
richten
[Musik]
im Alten Testament beim Propheten
Jeremia findet sich die einprägsame
Aufforderung
suchet das Stadt heute würde man Staat
sagen also suche das stadtbestes und
betet für sie zum Herrn denn wenn es ihr
wohl geht so geht es auch euch wohl
man kann über die Begründung
verschiedener Meinung sein die Bibel
versteht den Menschen als Verwalter
Gottes auf Erden dessen Aufgabe es ist
die Welt positiv und gut zu gestalten
aber unabhängig davon wie man die
Aufforderung begründet sie gilt doch für
uns alle und durchaus im eigenen
Interesse wenn es dem Staat wohlgeht so
geht es Euch uns allen gut deshalb
suchet das Stadt des Staates Bestes und
dient ihm uns den Menschen das passt
doch wunderbar zum Beruf einer Soldatin
eine Soldaten zu jungen Unteroffizieren
und offizierinnen ihren Dienst im
österreichischen Bundesheer
Friede ist immer möglich
aber was kann ich dafür tun
hilf mir heute Herr mit Frieden im
kleinen anzufangen
die Meinung der anderen zu achten ein
grobes Wort nicht zu erwidern
eine Nachteil auch einmal in Kauf zu
nehmen einem Unrecht nicht beizustimmen
gut und Rat anzunehmen nicht immer
zuerst an mich zu denken
Friede ist möglich aber nicht immer
leicht ich möchte den Mut aufbringen
Dinge zu ändern die ich ändern kann
gib uns diesen Mut her damit wir heute
mit gutem Willem auch die rechte Tat
vollbringen Amen
hohe Festgäste liebe anzugegebende
Kameraden liebe Brüder und Schwester
lasset uns für den Frieden beten
herr Jesus Christus unser Gott sehe mit
einem barmherzigen Auge auf das Leid und
auf die
hörbaren Schreie deine Kinder in dem
Lande Ukraine
befreie sie von brüdermoderischen Krieg
und beende ihr Blutvergießen heile das
entstandene Unglück und führe die die
ihr Dach verloren haben in ihre Häuser
zurück gibt zu essen den Hungernden
schenke Trost den weinenden und Vereine
die die zuvor auseinandergerissen wurden
verlasse deine Herde nicht mildere die
Kränkungen derer die von ihren nächsten
böses erfahren mussten und schenke ihnen
Versöhnung durch eine Gnade
er weiche die verhärteten Herzen und
bekehre sie zu deinem GDR Erkenntnis
schenke Friede deine Kirche und ihren
treuen Kindern damit sie mit einem
Herzen und mit einem Wunde dich unseren
Herrn und Erlöser verherrlichen jetzt
und immer da und von Ewigkeit zu
Ewigkeit Amen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
wertekameraden mit dem Namen Gottes des
alabams des barmherzigen
Barmherzigkeit ist eine Eigenschaft des
menschlichen Charakters jeder Mensch ist
grundsätzlich in der Lage seine
tugendhaften Eigenschaften zu erkennen
zu entwickeln und im positiven Sinne zu
nutzen in diesem Sinne wünsche ich Ihnen
viel Kraft und Erfolg in Zeiten großer
Herausforderungen möge Gott
in unserem Land Österreich in Europa und
in der ganzen Menschheit die Liebe die
Barmherzigkeit die Solidarität und vor
allem den Frieden herrschen lassen Armin
sehr geschätzte Damen und Herren liebe
Zuseherinnen und Zuseher beim Livestream
sie hören jetzt den traditionsmarsch der
jahresunteroffiziersakademie den
friedrich-marsch im Anschluss spricht
der Herr Bürgermeister der Stadt Enns
Christian die lehrerhotka
[Musik]
sehr geehrter stellvertretende Chef des
Generalstabs general mayor Magister
Rudolf Striedinger sehr geehrte Frau
landeshauptmann-stellvertreterin
Magistra Christine haberlander sehr
geehrter Herr Kommandant der Ruag
oberstes Generalstabs Magister Klaus
klingenschmidt geschätzte Geistlichkeit
Liebe Offiziere und offizierinnen
geschätzte Abgeordnete zum Nationalrat
geschätzte Ehrengäste Werte Damen und
Herren und ZuseherInnen sehr geschätzte
wachtmeisterinnen und Wachtmeister es
ist mir eine Ehre sie an diesem
feierlichen Festtag zur Ausmusterung der
Wachtmeister erstmals als Bürgermeister
im Namen der Stadt Enns herzlich
begrüßen zu dürfen ich freue mich
viele junge Unteroffiziere im schönen
historischen Ambiente der
heeresunteroffiziersakademie in der
ältesten Stadt Österreichs willkommen zu
heißen
die huak ist eine wichtige
Ausbildungsstätte erfolgreicher Fach-
und Führungskräfte des österreichischen
Bundesheeres und sie leistet auch einen
wesentlichen Beitrag dazu dass die Stadt
weit über die Landesgrenzen hinaus
bekannt ist sie stellt für uns einen
unverzichtbaren Wirtschaftsfaktor da und
ist ein fixer und wertvoller Bestandteil
unserer Tradition und unserer Geschichte
in der ältesten Stadt Österreichs
die Stadt Enns und ihre Bürger und
Bürgerinnen hatten schon immer ein enges
von gegenseitiger Wertschätzung
geprägtes Verhältnis zur
heeresunteroffiziersakademie dies ist
auch in einem Partnerschaftsvertrag
dokumentiert und diese Partnerschaft
steht nicht nur auf dem Papier sie wird
gelebt neben gemeinsamen Veranstaltungen
ist es auch die verlässliche und
unverzichtbare Hilfe bei
Hochwasserkatastrophen oder anderen
Notsituationen die wir in der Stadt Enns
sehr zu schätzen wissen
ein neues Symbol dieser unserer gelebten
Partnerschaft sind die Bäume die wie
seitens der Stadt Enns für jeden
Ausbildungslehrgang gestiftet und
gemeinsam gepflanzt werden
sehr geschätzte Damen und Herren und
Offiziere sie haben sich alle der
fordernden Ausbildung unterzogen und
damit entschieden
dem Dienst an der Republik zu leisten
mit der Ernennung zum Wachtmeister haben
Sie den ersten Meilenstein in ihrer
Laufbahn als Unteroffizier bewältigt
ihnen kommt künftig eine Schlüsselrolle
bei der Ausbildung der
wehrdienstpflichtigen zu und sind
übernehmen damit auch eine enorme
Verantwortung gerade in Tagen wie diesen
meine sehr geschätzten Damen und Herren
wir wird uns wieder bewusst gemacht wie
sehr sich das Aufgabengebiet des
österreichischen Bundesheers verändert
hat es ist nicht einfacher es ist im
Gegenteil größer komplexer schwieriger
geworden
oberste Prämisse des Bundesheeres ist
aber immer noch der Schutz von
Demokratie Frieden und von
Menschenrechten und dafür danke ich
Ihnen allen ich möchte Ihnen für einen
Einsatz und für ihre gewählte berufliche
Ausgabe meine Anerkennung meinen res
Projekte und ein aufrichtiges Dankeschön
aussprechen und wünsche Ihnen für einen
weiteren Lebensweg und ihre zukünftige
soldatenlaufbahn alles Gute und viel
Erfolg bei der Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben
im Dienste unserer Republik Österreich
danke
geschätzte ehren und Festgäste sie hören
jetzt die Grußworte des Landes
Oberösterreich es spricht die Frau
landeshauptmann-stellvertreterin Frau
Magister Christine haberlander daran
anschließend folgt der Marsch der
unteroffiziersgesellschaft
hohe Geistlichkeit sehr geehrter Herr
generalmaier-stridinger sehr geehrte
Abgeordnete sehr geehrte ehren- und
Festgäste sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister gleich einleitend eine
herzliche Gratulation zur
abgeschlossenen Ausbildung diese
Glückwünsche darf ich Ihnen nicht nur im
eigenen Namen sondern ganz besonders
auch im Namen unseres Landeshauptmanns
Thomas Stelze überbringen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren wir sind heute hier in
einem sonnigen Freitag im wunderschönen
Enns zusammengekommen um den
wachtmeisterinnen und Wachtmeister ins
absolvierten ausbildungser herzlich zu
gratulieren wir sind hier und heute in
Friede und Freiheit
zusammengekommen und man kann in Tagen
wie diesen keine Rede oder kein Gespräch
führen ohne das aktuell beherrschende
Thema zu ignorieren daher möchte ich
dazu ein paar Worte sagen
etwas über 1000 km Entfernung von hier
überschlagen sich seit Tagen der
geeignisse die Situation ist sehr ernst
und besorgniserregend und die Bilder von
Zerstörung Leid und Elend sind sehr sehr
schwer zu ertragen und machen bedrückt
und nachdenklich es ist nicht leicht all
diese tragischen Neuigkeiten zu hören
aus diesem Grund ist es mehr als
verständlich dass die
Verteidigungsministerin heute nicht
persönlich anwesend sein kann
die aktuelle Situation zeigt wie wichtig
eine gute Landesverteidigung für ein
Land ist entscheidend ist dabei vor
allem eine gute Ausbildung der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten in
Oberösterreich sehen wir in Bildung die
beste Vorbereitung für das zukünftige
Leben Bildung öffnet Türen schafft
Perspektiven und die Möglichkeit für
jeden einzelnen seine Talente zu
entfalten sie haben Ihre Ausbildung
einen anerkannten Kompetenzzentrum des
bundeshersehen ens absolviert mit
anderen Worten sie stehen jetzt für die
Kompetenz dieses Hauses sie ist auf sie
übergegangen ich sage dies auch als
voller Stolz als Bürgerin der Stadt Enns
und wir verdanken hier in Enns der
Bürgermeister hatte schon ausgeführt den
Bundes sehr sehr viel und ein großes
Danke an dieser Stelle auch für die gute
Partnerschaft und Verbundenheit
jede und jeder Absolvent ist eine
wertvolle Verstärkung nicht nur für das
österreichische Bundesheer sondern für
die Gesamtgesellschaft unseres Landes
mit ihrer Ausbildung mit ihrem Wissen
und ihren Skills über diese jetzt
verfügen stehen sie für die
Leistungsfähigkeit unseres Bundesheers
das gibt ihren Angehörigen Eltern
Freunden und Partnern das Recht stolz zu
sein und bedeutet für uns alle als
Gesellschaft das beruhigende Gefühl und
im Ernstfall auf rasche und sachkundige
Hilfe durch das Bundesheer verlassen zu
können
diese Ernstfall kann viele Gesichter
haben die Zweifel daran hat wohl die
corona-gesundheitskrise endgültig
überzeugt ich danke daher auch an dieser
Stelle als gesundheitslandesrätin für
alle Einsätze und Hilfestellungen von
Seiten des Bundesheers in den letzten
zwei Jahren sie waren und sind unser
Land Oberösterreichers Krisenstab des
Landes ein wertvoller Partner und ich
bin stolz auf unser Bundesheer und dass
wir gut zusammenarbeiten dürfen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren es gilt
jeder Abschluss ist auch ein Neubeginn
für diesen neugierbeginn wünsche ich
Ihnen viel Freude Kraft und Erfolg sie
gehören jetzt zu den Leuchttürmen und zu
den Visitenkarten des österreichischen
Bundesheers denn es wird zu ihrer
Aufgabe gehören junge Menschen in einen
Lebensabschnitt zu begleiten und auch
dafür sind sie ausgebildet worden zu
führen
Persönlichkeitsentwicklung ist daher ein
integraler Bestandteil ihrer Ausbildung
gewesen auch dafür ist diese Akademie
längst zum internationaler Kanten
Kompetenzzentrum geworden denn zum Bild
dass die Menschen im Land von Bundesheer
haben gehört der eigene Wehrdienst
ebenso wie die vielen Male in denen das
Bundesheer an Ort und Stelle ist wenn es
dringend gebraucht wird
insgesamt hat sich das Bundesheer heute
als Garant für die Sicherheit und als
Garant für Hilfe in schwierigen
Situationen fest im Bewusstsein der
Öffentlichkeit verankert im Namen des
Landes Oberösterreich seinen herzlichen
Dank für diesen Einsatz mit dieser
Verankerung sind dann auch die Debatten
über die Sinnhaftigkeit eines eigenen
österreichischen Bundesheers längst aus
der öffentlichen Diskussion zurecht
verschwunden denn niemand zerreißt eine
versicherungspolize den so vielen Krisen
und Katastrophenfällen in der Lage ist
schnell und wirkungsvoll zu helfen
ich danke Ihnen dass Sie sich mit Ihrer
Ausbildung entschieden haben dafür einen
Beitrag zu leisten in diesem Sinn noch
einmal herzliche Gratulation zur
absolvierten Ausbildung alles Gute für
die Zukunft
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren es erfolgt
nun stellvertretend für alle Absolventen
die Beförderung der vier
lehrgangssprecher der Frauenbeauftragten
sowie der Vertreterin der
miliziumtoffiziere
an den lehrgangsbesten des Lehrgangs
feldpilot Karl Urban wird das
Ehrengeschenk der goldene Ring der
heeresunteroffiziersakademie überreicht
lehrgangsbester ist Herr Wachtmeister
Apple Philipp
er hat bei den dienstprüfungen alle
möglichen Auszeichnungen das sind zehn
an der Zahl erreicht
er wird Dienst als Heeres
Leistungssportler im militärischen
Fünfkampf bei mehrere Sportzentrum
versehen
hören Sie im Anschluss an die Ehrungen
die Ansprache des Lehrgangs besten
gefolgt vom Marsch oder mein Österreich
und Abordnungen vortreten
ich bitte jetzt den stellvertretenden
Chef des Generalstabs den
akademiekommandanten und den Kunden
anderen duplizieren Akademie die
Ehrungen und Beförderungen vorzunehmen
die Damen und Herren Wachtmeister
Absolventen der fünften
kardanwärtausbildung 3 führenden
lehrgangsnamen feldpilot Karl Urban
Offizier Stellvertreter urban
1894 in Graz geboren
diente nach seiner Pilotenausbildung im
Einsatz an der russischen Front
er entwickelte sich rasch zum besten
Piloten seiner Einheit
bis 1916 wurde er dreimal mit der
silbernen Tapferkeitsmedaille erster
Klasse ausgezeichnet
im selben Jahr wurde während eines
Langstrecken beobachtungsfluges schwer
verwundet
trotzdem gelang es ihm seine Maschine
hinter den eigenen Linien Not zu landen
diese tapfere Tat wurde zum Anlass
genommen
urban mit der goldenen
Tapferkeitsmedaille auszuzeichnen
nach seiner Genesung gelang es ihm bis
1918 fünf Luftsiege für sich in Anspruch
zu nehmen
was ihm nach den internationalen Regeln
seiner Zeit zum Fliegerass machte
sind den letzten Flug absolviert der im
Juli 1918 als Testpilot
er kam dabei ironischerweise aufgrund
von Materialversagen aus 1500 Meter Höhe
zum ungebremsten Absturz
offizierstellvertreter urban wurde kurz
darauf postum zum zweiten Mal mit der
goldenen Tapferkeitsmedaille
ausgezeichnet
durch seine Tapferkeit und sein
dienstverständnis
dient Karl Urban uns undoffizieren in
Gegenwart und Zukunft als Vorbild in der
Füllung unserer Aufgaben
sehr geehrter general major ja
akademiekommandant
wertekameradinnen und Kameraden es ist
meine Ehre heute als kursbester der
fünften kardanwärter Ausbildung 3 zu
Ihnen zu sprechen
die vergangenen 18 Monate waren für mich
und wie ich denke für viele von ihnen
nicht leicht
die drei kartanwärterkurse zur Erlangung
des dienstgrads Wachtmeister waren von
Höhen und Tiefen geprägt
aber gerade dass wir Winden dieser
tiefen Momente der psychischen und
physischen Anstrengung
haben uns als Menschen als Soldaten
geformt und sind der Grund dafür warum
wir stolz sein können heute hier zu
stehen
doch alleine ohne gegenseitige
Unterstützung hätten wir das nicht
geschafft
deshalb möchte ich mich an dieser Stelle
bei Ihnen für die gelebte und erlebte
Kameradschaft
auf den verschiedenen Kursen
was die Zeit dort wesentlich erleichtert
hat bedanken
beispielhaft erinnere ich mich gerne an
die Gebirgsausbildung noch filzen
in diesen zwei Wochen war das Wetter
nicht angenehm Regen Schnee Wind
wir haben zu fünft wir haben uns zu fünf
vier Schlafplätze geteilt aber trotzdem
ist der schmier immer grenzt und die
Stimmung war gut
das eine oder andere hoppala hat dann
auch seinen Teil zu guten Stimmung
beigetragen
dieser Umstand hat diese Zeit dort
wesentlich erleichtert aus diesem
Kameraden sind mittlerweile Freunde
geworden sie sind heute ebenfalls
anwesend und ich freue mich sehr an
eurer Seite als Wachtmeister
außenmustern
ich habe als Leistungssportler des
herrensportzentrums die
kardanwärter-kurse begonnen und zu
Beginn war ich mir unsicher wie ich mich
dort aufgrund meiner eher geringen
militärischen Erfahrung schlagen werde
sehr schnell habe ich aber Parallelen
zwischen meiner sportlichen Alltag und
der militärischen Dienstbetrieb gefunden
und ich habe bemerkt dass eine gute
sportliche Leistungsfähigkeit die
militärischen Dienstbetrieb erheblich
erleichtert
oft waren es die vierten Soldaten die
ihre etwas schwächeren Kameraden und
Kameradinnen bei den körperlich sehr
anspruchsvollen Aufgaben welche aber in
der Natur des soldatenberufs liegen
unterstützt haben
wir haben als Soldaten wir haben als
Soldaten das Privileg Sport in der
Dienstzeit zu treiben
nutzen Sie diese Chance und gehen sie
als künftige Kommandanten als gutes
Beispiel voran
des Weiteren bedanke ich mich beim
Ausbildungspersonal des
institut-akademie
diese haben wesentlich zum positiven
Abschluss
unserer Ausbildung zum Unteroffizier
beigetragen
ich möchte meine Rede mit einem Zitat
dass mich auch Sportler jahrelang
begleitet hat
als auch in meiner militärischen
Laufbahn vielleicht nicht wortwörtlich
aber im eigentlichen Sinn hat geprägt
beenden
wir müssen nicht Weltklasse sein um
anzufangen aber wir müssen anfangen um
Weltklasse zu sein danke
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Werte Zuseher beim Livestream hören Sie
nun die Ansprache des militärische
höchst amwesenden ein Generalmajor
Magister Rudolf Striedinger
verteilen sie geschätzte Damen und
Herren ein Fehler in meinem Ablauf
zuerst bitte ich natürlich die
Militärmusik um das Musikstück oder um
in Österreich danke
schön
[Musik]
hohe Geistlichkeit
sehr geehrte Landeshauptmann
Stellvertreterin
sehr geehrte Abgeordnete Herr
Bürgermeister
meine sehr verehrten Kommandanten und
Dienststellenleiter des österreichischen
Bundesheeres sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
aber vor allem sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Wachtmeister die sie heute
ausgemustert werden
wie sie alle bereits gehört haben ist
sowohl die Frau Bundesministerin als
auch der gemeinschaftchef in Wien
gebunden aufgrund der aktuellen Lage und
daher hat mich die Bundesministerin
beauftragt an ihrer Stelle ein paar
Worte an sie zu richten und ich zitiere
daher Sie persönlich
in Krisenzeiten wachsen oft ungeahnte
Kräfte und in einer Gefahrensituation
ist schnelles zielgerichtetes Handeln
gefragt
mir ist es bewusst dass viele von ihnen
nach mittlerweile fast zwei Jahren
Pandemie oft eine schwere Zeit
durchgemacht haben nicht nur weil die
vielen assistenzeinsätze und
Unterstützungsleistungen im Kampf der
Gesundheitsbehörden gegen das
Coronavirus zu einer äußerst Ton
Einsatzbelastung im Inland geführt haben
sondern auch weil viele
Ausbildungsvorhaben entweder abgesagt
oder stark eingeschränkt werden mussten
aber lassen Sie mich eines dazu
festhalten
klar ist dass die Hauptaufgabe des
Bundesheeres die militärische
Landesverteidigung ist
das Bundesheer ist aber auch die
strategische Reserve der Republik
die Bevölkerung verlässt sich auf uns
wir helfen dann wenn andere nicht mehr
können und gerade in einer Pandemie
müssen ohnehin alle in einem Staat
zusammenhelfen
sonst geht sie nie vorbei
eine Pandemie geht uns alle etwas an ob
ihr das jetzt wollen oder nicht
die aktuelle Situation in der Ukraine
zeigt uns aber auch ganz deutlich
wie wichtig
exzellente Ausbildung und Expertise sind
erst kürzlich erreichte mich die
Nachricht dass 14 Leutnant Wolfgang
Brunner Kommando und Offizier der
vierten Panzergrenadierbrigade gerade
äußerst erfolgreich sein drittes
Semester an der Sargent nature Academy
in Texas absolviert hat und diese
Ausbildung als erster und Offizier mit
einem Bachelor abschließen wird
ich bin sehr stolz auf den hohen
Standard der Ausbildung an der
heeresrundoffiziersakademie und auf die
ausgezeichnete Repräsentation
Österreicher undoffiziere im Ausland
ich darf Ihnen allen zu ihrer
absolvierten Leistung gratulieren
es ist ein großer Tag für Sie alle weil
die Beförderung zum Wachtmeister ein
bedeutender Schritt in ihrer Karriere
ist und weil sie erfolgreich die
Ausbildung zum Unteroffizier
abgeschlossen haben
sie mussten jetzt zu ihren Verbänden aus
und werden diese mit ihrer Arbeit
wesentlich unterstützen nun können Sie
zeigen und anwenden was sie gelernt
haben und ihre Führungsstärke beweisen
ich wünsche Ihnen dabei alles Gute viel
Erfolg und viel Soldaten Glück
soweit die Worte unserer Frau
Bundesministerin
lassen Sie mich
auch aus der militärischen Sicht ein
paar Worte an Sie richten sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren Wachtmeister
sie haben in einer herausfordernden Zeit
ihre Ausbildung zum mundoffizier
begonnen
die Frau Bundesminister hat es mit der
Pandemie zum Ausdruck gebracht
und sie schließen diese Ausbildung in
einer für Europa durchaus katastrophalen
Lage ab
trotzdem und gerade deswegen
bedanke ich mich bei Ihnen dass Sie sich
diese Ausbildung unterzogen haben dass
sie diesen Entschluss gefasst haben
entweder im österreichischen Bundesheer
als berufsunteroffizier
oder als Miliz Unteroffizier ihren
Beitrag für die Sicherheit der Republik
leisten zu wollen
ich bedanke mich aber auch bei der
Heeres und offiziersakademie und bei den
Truppen und Dienststellen die einen
wesentlichen Beitrag dazu geleistet
haben dass Sie heute hier stehen können
in der Qualität und ich habe das von
ihrem Kommandanten erfahren bei einer
ausgezeichneten Qualität wo das
österreichische Bundesheer wieder mal
froh sein kann so viele hunderte und
Offiziere zur Unterstützung unseres
Einsatzes und unserer Aufgaben zur
Verfügung zu bekommen
wir befinden uns derzeit als
österreichisches Bundesheer in einer
Dauerlast in einer Überlastung
die Aufgaben sind deutlich höher als das
was das österreichische Bundesheer auf
Dauer wird leisten können
und daher ist es unsere Aufgabe der
militärischen Führung mit der Zeit auch
in der Politik klar zu machen dass wir
hier eine entsprechende Entlastung
brauchen werden
die Zeit arbeitet ein bisschen für uns
wir hoffen dass wir zumindest in den
nächsten Monaten etwas verschont werden
was die Pandemie betrifft und arbeiten
intensiv daran dass sie uns im Herbst
nicht wieder so einholt wie im
vergangenen Herbst
was ist unser Ziel
wir wollen dass wir unsere
Grundwehrdiener die zum österreichischen
Bundesheer einrücken wieder ordentlich
sechs Monate ausbilden können und es
wird genau ihre Aufgabe sein diese
verantwortungsvolle Ausbildung unserer
österreichischen Staatsbürger in einer
Qualität sicherzustellen dass wir nach
sechs Monaten
einsatzbereite Soldaten haben in aller
Regel und hoffentlich auch vermehrt für
die Miliz
so dass wir in der Lage sind auf Dauer
ein Bundesheer zur Verfügung zu haben
dass uns immer wieder in krisenhaften
Situationen helfen kann
das berufskaderpersonal die
berufsunteroffiziere sollen daher in
Zukunft vermehrt wieder Ausbildung
betreiben Einsatz Vorbereitung
durchführen und damit im Rahmen von
Übungen das militärische Handwerk zu
üben und zu beherrschen
damit wir in der Lage sind unsere
militärische Landesverteidigung auch
tatsächlich mit Leben zu befüllen
unsere Bearbeitungen dazu auf der
militärstrategischen Ebene haben ergeben
und das ist auch nichts Neues
dass wir mit der Erfüllung von
militärischen Kernkompetenzen in der
Lage sind alles andere alles andere was
von uns verlangt wird zu erledigen
die Miliz und Offiziere und unter ihnen
darf ich ersuchen ihre
Einsatzbereitschaft aufrecht zu erhalten
durch Übungen und auch durch Einsätze im
In- und Ausland für das österreichische
Bundesheer
sein Zielsetzung muss es sein dass wir
im Wesentlichen aus der Miliz heraus die
Einsätze des Bundesheeres tragen können
und aus der Präsenz heraus entsprechend
verstärkt
was erwarten wir von Ihnen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren Wachtmeister
soldatische Tugenden und Vorbild sein
das ist das was am wichtigsten oberster
Stelle steht
das Einbringen ihrer fachlichen
Expertise
und Menschlichkeit
im gegenseitigen Umgang und insbesondere
dann wenn ihnen Soldaten übertragen sind
zur Verantwortung zu Ausbildung
insbesondere Grundwehrdiener darf ich
Sie darum bitten mit diesen Soldaten
menschlich umzugehen
sie haben mit ihrem jahrgangsnamen
Offizier Stellvertreter Karl Urban Pilot
im Ersten Weltkrieg jemanden gewählt
von dem sie sich ein Vorbild nehmen
können ich gehe davon aus dass sie
ungefähr wissen wie er seine
dienstlichen Verpflichtungen
wahrgenommen hat
er hat seine persönlichen Fähigkeiten
seinen Intellekt
zum Einsatz gebracht
er hat sich durch Tapferkeit
ausgezeichnet er hat besonderes
Durchhaltevermögen an den Tag gelegt ihr
Jahrgangs erster hat die Notwendigkeit
von Durchhaltevermögen unterstrichen er
hat Kameradschaft einen Tag gelegt
und er hat auch in offensichtlich
ausweglosen Situationen immer wieder das
Richtige gemacht und das damit Erfolg
erzielt
ich möchte Ihnen daher abschließend
wirklich alles Gute in ihrer beruflichen
und ihrer milizverwendung für das
österreichische Bundesheer wünschen
soldatenglück und diejenigen die tüchtig
sind haben es zumeist es lebe das
österreichische Bundesheer es lebe die
Republik Österreich
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ich ersuche Sie nun sich für die
Europahymne von ihren Plätzen zu erheben
das ganze hat
och ehrenkomponie
[Musik]
geschätzte Gäste Werte Damen und Herren
ich bitte Sie wieder Platz zu nehmen
Oberst rudolf-halbertschlager der
Kommandant der ausgerückten Truppe wird
im Anschluss dem stellvertretenden
generalstoffchef melden und um weitere
Befehle bitten
davor erlaube ich mir noch einige
wesentliche Informationen zum weiteren
Ablauf des Festakts zu geben
sie geschätzte
sind im Anschluss sehr herzlich zum
Empfang im Wirtschaftsgebäude welche
sich unmittelbar hinter ihnen befindet
eingeladen
die angetretene Truppe wird durch die
Garde Musik ausgespielt und marschiert
zum Hauptgebäude oststiege das ist der
parkseitige Eingang
dort wird verbandsweise eine
Erinnerungsfoto der ausgemusterten
Wachtmeister mit den Kommandanten der
großen und kleinen Verbände angefertigt
beginnend mit der sechsten
gebirgsbrigade und der 7 jägerbrigade
alle anderen Kommandanten und die
Wachtmeister des ausmusterungsjahrgangs
2022 bitte ich nach dem abtreten die
sammelräume der Kaserne zu beziehen
dort haben Sie die Möglichkeit mit einem
Getränk auf die Beförderung in die
Dienstgrad Wachtmeister anzustoßen
von der sammelräumen werden sie durch
einen Gästebetreuer nach einem
festgelegten Ablaufplan zum Fototermin
abgeholt bzw begleitet
die sammelräume sind ausgeschildert
sowie in der eingangs erhaltenen
schriftlichen Informationen angeführt
geschätzte Damen und Herren Werte
Zuseherinnen und Zuseher bei der
Live-Übertragung ich bedanke mich sehr
herzlich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und Ihr
Interesse an unserem Festakt auf
Wiedersehen an der
heeresunteroffiziersakademie
[Musik]
zur Meldung Anwesen das ganze rechts
schon
gemeldet die Beendigung des feierlichen
Festaktes und bittet um weitere
befehlest herzlichen Dank für die
ausgezeichnete Kommandoführung für mich
keine Überraschung ich bedanke mich auch
bei der Karte und der Gardemusik für die
ausgezeichnete Umrahmung dieses
Festaktes abrücken
[Musik]
auswasch der Insignien das ganze habt
zum ausmarschen Singen der
heeresunteroffizierter das ganze
[Musik]
die Information übernehmen
ehrenformationen
[Musik]